egle oh I think you are slowly turning
me gay
I might unsub love the videos though hey
guys excited to jump back into the
comments section let's see what you gave
me this week fedora me aza deer dr. Mike
what happens if I get struck by
lightning I think you get severely
burned a lightning strike because of
electrical activity can also stop your
heart but I know people who have gotten
struck by lightning at least from the
news and survived never seen a patient
get struck by lightning I think the odds
are something like 1 in 4,000 that you
can get struck by lightning need to look
that up I'll pop it up on screen in my
edit should a doctor treat relatives or
patients that they know if yes how to
affect their objectivity and judgment it
depends on the doctor Ozanne some
doctors can still be objective in
treating their friends and family not
ideal because again you can make some
bad decisions when treating your friends
or family in fact my dad whenever I was
ill even though he's a doctor he would
always take me to see another doctor
because he would say like another set of
eyes that's not bias it doesn't see you
every day they can sort of catch things
that maybe his I won't catch and I agree
with that
Louis de Bourgh career economic sentence
farmer judge stroke burning attribute
slamming tents frankly truth be told
George Washington's pet puppy came at
the light of the bookshelf on the TV
stand who stood upon the wires
microphone etc hope that answered your
question what was that Karen app
felonies hey doctor Mike you are awesome
thank you I was wondering what body fat
percentage is too low for men or for
women we hear a lot about being
overweight but commonly not about being
too thin you look at Instagram and some
of these physiques that you see they're
not realistic one of two things is
happening
you're really getting really extreme
plastic surgery or you're photoshopping
yourself to look thinner than you
actually are now the way that you should
look at it is not so much by a body fat
but looking at your BMI which compares
your height to your weight and there's a
chart for this where you can actually
see your
and then match your weight and see what
number you are eighteen point five to
twenty four point nine is the normal
range anything above twenty four point
nine to thirty is overweight above
thirties obese below eighteen point five
is underweight see where you fall in
that little range and then go talk to
your doctor and have a conversation
about it please make a podcast I would
love to learn new things from you during
my commute cells I want to make a
podcast I feel like I have a lot to say
I've learned a lot of my journey and
while this is a great way for us to
communicate I feel like a podcast where
I can sort of just tell you how I feel
and talk about some current events maybe
have some guests on the show and have
interesting conversations
that's something I'm excited about maybe
Salle's you can do me a favor you can
write a comment down below and say
anyone who wants dr. Mike to start a
podcast about this and I'm going to give
you a challenge 20,000 up votes I will
begin the process of starting a podcast
the challenge has been given Megan Meier
hey dr. Mike does lightning McQueen get
car insurance or life insurance
Lightning McQueen Lightning McQueen
sounds like a character from one of
those things cars God I'm so out of
touch with reality that's what happens
when you're trapped in the hospital they
if it's a car I would say car insurance
because if a car dies the life insurance
company is gonna sue the car insurance
company and it's a whole lot of
insurance nonsense and I hate insurance
this is why lawyers make so much money
and doctors don't because they build by
like the minute as opposed to doctors
were all altruistic folks they just want
to help everybody not hating on lawyers
you do some great work so do you have
doctor related dreams for example do you
dream about medical procedure surgeries
etc actually Allison I've had some
dreams like that and they weren't
nightmares like I would go in 10 Jack
the knee with steroids for someone who
has really bad osteoarthritis and when I
would start injecting the steroid Vinny
just starts swelling like crazy and
blood goes everywhere and it was a
legitimate nightmare that I had over and
over again during my training I have no
idea why hjk hi dr. Mike what is the
science behind being lactose and tell
I think you mean lactose-intolerant but
I get it I am lactose intolerant and I
have been trying to drink milk more
often to help get my body liking again
can that actually work thank you not a
good idea because your body is already
saying that it doesn't like milk when
you're lactose intolerant you're not
having an autoimmune reaction you're
just missing the enzyme that breaks down
the sugar component of milk which is
lactose and the enzyme that you're
missing is lactase sometimes people do
well with a pill form of the enzyme
lactase that doesn't work for everybody
and it's sort of hit or miss my advice
would be just to skip out on dairy foods
as often as possible make sure you're
getting calcium and vitamin D from other
sources because usually that's one of
the main sources of calcium and vitamin
D for most folks but if you're gonna
enjoy some cheese some pizza some cereal
make sure you do it when no one's around
because I know those symptoms can be
rough how do I tell my doctor I've
depression because when I start to bring
it up I get anxiety and just back out
well Angela this is sort of the doctors
job they're supposed to make you feel
comfortable they're supposed to ask you
some guided questions to allow you to
express the way you feel without making
you feel uncomfortable that doesn't mean
there's nothing to do on your part you
should still really work to make sure
that your feelings come out honestly
openly and truthfully because when you
do that not only will you get a big
sense of relief by just getting that
information out there but then with that
information the doctor can then go ahead
and help you and it doesn't mean
necessarily if they're gonna prescribe
your medication so many people are
afraid that oh the doctors just gonna
tell me to take a pill and I don't want
to take a pill there are a lot of
treatments for depression that are not
just pharmacologic don't feel down
Angela stay confident tell your doctor
the truth be honest and open and reap
the benefits of getting your treatment
Kelly
Kawaguchi does apple cider vinegar
really have all the benefits that people
claim no apple cider vinegar is not the
next coming honestly I blame the media
for this someone came up with some study
that showed that in mice
there was a slight decrease in
blood sugar levels and diabetic mice and
now they claim that apple cider vinegar
cures all it does not I do need to do a
little bit more research to find out
exactly how it affects each condition
but I promise you it does not solve
every problem and you shouldn't use it
as a cure-all for everything in fact
I've seen some patients use it and
actually have some stomach upset and
have some other problems developed as a
result of using it hey dr. Mike how
often should you shower for someone with
eczema or dandruff well cheese guy guy
guy guy one if you have dandruff using a
shampoo that is specifically anti
dandruff shampoo is ideal you could also
use some natural oils like tea tree oil
or manuka oil or coconut oil I've seen
some good results with that if you
shower very often for someone who has
eczema you can overly dry out your skin
and cause eczema symptoms to get worse
also very important that when you're
susceptible to eczema and you want to
dry yourself after a shower don't rub
your skin just pat yourself dry so you
don't irritate the skin any more than it
needs to be
hey dr. Mike I'm curious what is the
most embarrassing moment of your life
Muniz I've said this before and I'll say
it again and it's sad so get ready for a
sad story I was four years old and my
brain had just turned on because I was
making memories and I remember this I
was in pre-k and it was nap time and I
pooped my pants a little bit and I had
diarrhea and in Russia since they were
very strict and disciplinarian if you
will they made me walk around naked
while they washed my underwear in the
water fountain in the sink and another
teacher walked in just as they were
doing that and I had to stand there
naked cold it was cold too and they were
cleaning out my poop it's very
embarrassing that moment stuck with me I
will never poop my pants again until
maybe I'm very very old and I'm
incontinent and at which point I wore
diapers so I don't have to wash my
underwear
ell me make sure nobody has to see me
nude except my nurse or my caretaker or
my doctor or my family members this has
turned into a weird story from a sad
story and I'm sorry you had to hear this
I love responding and reading your
comments you guys crack me up with your
questions I love trying these new
formats also so if you have a format
that you've seen somewhere else or maybe
you've created in your mind and you want
me to do it drop me a line down below in
the comments because I don't only just
respond to comments and videos like this
I also jump into the comment section
respond directly to folks as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]